nearly all ten teams in the na LCS have
finalized their roster and there is only
one North American born mid laner in the
entire league
apparently Dignitas is paying hooni
one-third of their money for players and
again we're trying to solve this North
American League problem by importing
more players you've all heard the story
before year in and year out
na tries and fails at world and I'll be
honest I am tired of watching them try
to fix this problem by importing more
players for the region well the rest of
the world dominates international
tournaments with homegrown town let's
get into this again ok so last week
reminiscent to like every League of
Legends offseason as of late the
conversation of homegrown talent in
North America was super popular on
League of Legends Twitter the
conversation was kicked off when PO
Beltre and Demonte a top 3 na mid laner
and one of the region's most prominent
up-and-coming mid lane talents were left
off any rosters entirely now it's
obviously not a secret that North
America has struggled on the
international stage and ever since
bjergsen's breakout performance in 2014
with TSM many people have looked
internationally to bring players in and
change the landscape of North American
League of Legends so they can compete
internationally we have a new addition
to the team this year I'm not sure if
you heard he's joining us from SK
Telecom t1 where we want a couple of
rings over there and two-time world
champion John world champion two-time
the two-time Jack's PA with you aka Bing
you actually know his name and despite
any slow climb to becoming somewhat
relevant on the international stage
highlighted by obviously liquid
finishing in the finals of MSI this year
they have struggled to put up any
results on the biggest stage the world
championship there's nothing cheap
liquid can't do honey
this gaming will be eliminating the
third and final CS contender from world
Invictus gaming at first water finals
even after franchising the development
of the NA academy system and names like
who needs bang and kore JJ coming to the
league nothing seems to be working so as
we discussed a few weeks back when na
got needed out of yet another world
championship it's probably best if these
owners of na teams go back to the
drawing board maybe develop some talent
at home you know like the rest of the
world's been doing for years and kicking
their asses which is well exactly the
[ __ ] opposite of what's been
happening this opposite and some of the
biggest headlines this offseason so far
are centering around how much na is
willing to pay to import that town in
fact like I said so far there's only one
North American born mid laner in the
entire league so double if weighed in on
the subject on stream last week after a
poll belters massive quit longer about
not having a team very very true I will
say Eugene as the teammate was
absolutely incredible so [ __ ] good
man I actually really like playing with
Eugene I thought he was really good it's
actually crazy that people think he's
[ __ ] bad or not even worth like an
LCS spot I think he's easily top three
top four mid laner in LCS like you can
say Jensen and bjergsen are better than
him individually but I still think he's
he has a lot of potential and when I
played with him we made a great combo
man poke he's so good with the exception
of literally beer' auxin pobelter is the
winningest mid laner in the history of
the na LCS and this guy can't find a
team at all he was such a big game
performer when liquid was rising to the
top of the LCS and like double upset
he's just a great guy to have on your
team he makes everyone around him better
team
could be enough to start the fight out
they're gonna look forward old comes
across from these Orillia and here's the
beer side the first ones down on the
back line a huge stock up and Spence
Garrett's gone three kills already this
is gonna be the ACE there is no way out
for cloud nine stopwatch by his three
seconds liquorice flashes still being
chased he will certainly drop in the ACE
guarantees the basement samples and the
fact that he currently doesn't even have
a spot in na really shows the culture of
looking elsewhere for talent that exists
in the region now Demonte obviously
doesn't have the pedigree that pobelter
does but this is a young north american
mid laner who improved a lot last split
with Clark he recently spoke about the
decline in meaningfulness of the NA
Academy system on hot line League the
excited to do Academy and then it seemed
like really good everyone was really it
was pretty competitive split and then
just like over time it seems like the
Tories have just stopped caring as much
and you see more like you see more teams
I have maybe no coach or a budget coach
or like someone who doesn't know
anything or like you have five players
who probably don't know like you don't
even know if some of those players
should be there and it seems like over
time it's like or you just feel like
they need to give minimum salary to
these players and at Worlds this year he
spoke to us about just how hard it is to
break into that Academy system in the
first place well I think definitely
since like 2015-2016 they've added a lot
to the amateur scene like scouting
around is a pretty big deal but I do
think like na is lacking a lot compared
to something like youth because they
have so many national leagues so much
like different stuff like that
and in na the amateur league is like
collegiate but right but like collegiate
and what people think in collegiate is
kind of bad like kind of those players
are not ever gonna be good enough to go
pro for the most part obviously I think
there's gonna be some outliers like
sometime in the future but for sure I
think they need to be something like
right below scouting rounds that is like
a consistent year-round thing
what's more and maybe most troubling to
me is that in some cases these players
being brought into na aren't even
objective upgrades
[Music]
this team is pathetic Mooney is
obviously an incredible talent that you
can point to but players like Micah and
Ryoma are completely unknown entities
sometimes it feels like orgs are just
importing players for the sake of it
there's this constant narrative being
spun around these signings every time
like somehow imported players will bring
something unique to North American teams
that's somehow a different play style or
a different ideological approach to the
game is somehow gonna be the magic
recipe for success but I have to say I
am just not sold any look you can only
have two imports on your roster it's not
like you're going to be able to recreate
SKT in na there has to be a system in
place to develop the three North
American players on your team for the
region to level up international parth
echoed this exact same sentiment in a
recent interview with travis gaffer sure
so I obviously don't know too much in
detail but what other orbs do I can just
kind of give you our perspective what
we've done in the last I guess year and
a half so we so TSM holds our own
scouting grounds every year we invite
players from na Europe and everywhere
else that we can see that we can have
talent that conceivably fits into our
Academy or LCS system in some way and
every year our scouting ground is
different so last year specifically we
wanted to see like last year was the
first year we did it we wanted to see
what talent is available we invited a
lot of players from both U and na
historically there's actually not really
any evidence to show that mix rosters
are better than domestic ones sure a
team like cloud9
have had imported talent on the roster
during their success the last few years
but of the top teams they're the one
most reliant on their North American
core
they're also maybe the team who has best
utilized the Academy system to develop
names like zeizel and blabber into key
role players look at Europe where after
years of struggling internationally
fnatic and g2 have developed themselves
into top-tier international competitors
based around fully European town that's
the kind of future that could actually
exist for na so another year
and more of na trying to fix all its
problems with imports let me bring you
to a headline from last week that is
maybe the biggest example of this early
on in the free-agent frenzy everybody
was talking about huni's deal and
honestly it was met with a lot of
negative attention according to an
inventor / report Dignitas are spending
1/3 of the money they have allotted to
players on just whom that number is a
reported 2.3 million dollars over two
years as reported by ESPN the league
community seems to see this deal as a
symbol for the import craze that has
been this offseason because frankly it's
gonna be pretty hard for Dignitas to
find for other good players to put on
their roster when that much of their
salary is going towards one player they
also had 2 of the most promising
upcoming players in na Vulcan and
Demonte who have left the team to make
room for this huge contract something
they don't seem to be worried about at
all on Twitter look a few years ago when
franchising was implemented there was a
lot made about how this was gonna
strength in North America that teams
could take chances on young players
because there was no fear of relegation
but here we are two years later and
honestly that's just not happening it's
the same old [ __ ] so if you're
frustrated with yet another off season
like this I get it because I'm [ __ ]
frustrated too
so as we discussed a few weeks back when
na got heated out of yet another world
championship it's probably [ __ ] so as we
discussed a few weeks back when na got
heated out of this year's World
Championship it's probably bet
so as we discussed a few weeks back when
na got weeded out of this world [ __ ] you
god damn it